♪ ♪
>> Carley: THE MEDIA IS COMING
AFTER GOVERNOR FLORIDA
RON DeSANTIS AGAIN.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ACCUSING
THE PUBLIC LEADER OF A NATURAL
DISASTER.
>> Todd: SOME ARE ANGRY AFTER
THESE RESTRICTIONS AND COUNTIES
HIT HARDEST BY HURRICANE THE AN
END ALSO HAPPENED TO LEAN
REPUBLICAN.
>> Carley: JOE CONCHA AUTHOR
OF "COME ON, MAN" WOULD HE MAKE
OF THIS CRITICISM?
>> CURLEY, RON DeSANTIS IS
SEEN BY MANY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS THE BIGGEST
THREAT TO THEIR POWER.
BY FAR ON A NATIONAL LEVEL,
ESPECIALLY IF DONALD TRUMP DOES
NOT RUN FOR THE NOMINATION ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
AND POLL AFTER POLL SHOWS
RON DeSANTIS BEATING CHARLIE
CRIST A FORMER REPUBLICAN QUITE
EASILY DESPITE OVERWHELMINGLY
NEGATIVE AND DISHONEST PRESS
ABOUT THE SITTING GOVERNOR.
I'M STILL SEEING SO-CALLED NEWS
REPORTS, FOR EXAMPLE DeSANTIS
RIGHTS IN EDUCATION BILL.
THAT IS WHAT THE BILL IS CALLED,
DON'T SAY BILL.
YOU DON'T SEE IT MENTIONED IN
THAT BILL.
SO THAT IS THE THING HERE.
RON DeSANTIS WILL BE ATTACKED
AT ANY MOMENT AT ANY TIME
PARTICULARLY BY NATIONAL MEDIA
IN FLORIDA BECAUSE AGAIN, HE IS
SEEN AS SOMEBODY IF HE RUNS CAN
BE SOMEBODY WHO CAN IMPEDE THE
NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
SPOON ALSO, JOE I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION LEFT LOVE MAIL-IN
VOTING WHENEVER YOU CAN GET UP
BUT APPARENTLY NOT --
>> GOOD POINT.
>> Todd: DR. FAUCI DEFLECTING
SCHOOL CLOSURES WHILE ADMITTING
TO THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS FOR
CHILDREN.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE SHOULD REALIZE AND HAVE
REALIZED THAT THERE WILL BE
DELETERIOUS, COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES.
THEY ALWAYS COME BACK AND SAY
FAUCI WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
CLOSING SCHOOLS.
I HAD NOTHING TO DO.
LET'S GET DOWN TO THE EFFECTS.
>> Todd: BUT JOE, THAT IS NOT
WHAT THE TAPE SAYS AND THE TATE
DON'T LIE.
WATCH THIS FOR MARCH 2020.
>> SO CLEARLY IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES PARTICULARLY IN
AREAS WHERE THE COMMUNITY
SPREAD, THE SCHOOL SHOULD BE
CLOSED.
>> Todd: JOE, HAS HE OR WILL
HE EVER TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
WHAT HE COST THEM IT?
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT NARCISSIST
DO.
AND DR. FAUCI IS THE ULTIMATE
NARCISSIST.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO'S DONE FOR
TOO MANY INTERVIEWS AND NEVER
TURNS DOWN THE REQUEST.
IT SEEMS BECAUSE HE LOVES THE
SOUND OF HIS OWN VOICE.
IN THE BEGINNING I WAS THE FIRST
PERSON TO PRAISE HIM OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THEN AFTER A WHILE
YOU SAW THIS PATTERN OF SHOWING
UP ON TELEVISION AND SHOWING HIS
FEELINGS ON THINGS INSTEAD OF
THE DATA, THE FACTS AND NOW HE
IS SEEN TAKE SO OTHER FOLKS
UNFORTUNATELY, THE CDC, NIH AS
POLITICAL AND PUSHING A
POLITICAL AGENDA.
I DIDN'T SEE HIM SPEAKING UP
SOON ENOUGH, PARTICULARLY WHEN
MY KIDS WERE MASSED IN
KINDERGARTEN WHEN WE CLEARLY
SEEN IT MADE NO DIFFERENCE
WHETHER MASSED OR NOT.
AND THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN
SCHOOLS FAR SOONER AND WE SEE
THE EFFECTS OF KEEPING KIDS OUT
OF SCHOOL TOO LONG WHEN IT WAS
SEEN CLEARLY THAT WAS THE CASE.
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN BACK IN.
DR. FAUCI NEEDS TO GO AND
STOPPING ON TELEVISION SO MUCH
BECAUSE AGAIN THIS IS SOMEBODY
WHO IS MORE OF A POLITICAL POND
THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
>> Carley: AND EDUCATION IS A
MAJOR ISSUE LEADING TO THE
MIDTERMS.
EVERYBODY REMEMBERS WHICH GROUP
WAS TRYING TO SHUT SCHOOLS DOWN